hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to mere layers now
we've got a puzzle here and it's the
third puzzle that we've come across and
Quebec over here is da da da da which
isn't actually a letter that I believe
that's a number in morse code those are
numbers and if I'm not mistaken da da da
da da is one so this is supposed to go
in the first slot as far as I know zero
one damn it okay I'm completely wrong I
thought I knew my Morse code I mean that
one has a nine on it and that one isn't
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
why did the door open that way and not
the way that he was supposed to open I'm
gonna pull up a reference guide for
Morse code numbers because I know
letters pretty well but I I don't know
numbers but the numbers go in a specific
order so I thought I was right oh I had
it backwards oh I had it backwards oh
boy
hey hey hey hi how's going oh boy
[Music]
okay I think he's gone
we BK did it to Dodd that would be nine
that's nine right yeah no god I got it
backwards again did it did it it dies
for god I'm such an idiot goes from left
to right not break the left I'm a
freaking idiot
okay so then that one's definitely one
then this one might not be six what was
this one again f77 dit dit da da da is -
god damn it I'm I'm [ __ ] an idiot
that's no excuse I should have known
that that's that's on me that's on me
everybody that's on me okay so 21 you
see is that it indeed uh which is five
even put this in the five point that
should be it
ah [ __ ] oh hey oh oh oh oh oh I
didn't get it I don't think right back
I'll be right back
I'll be right back that's two that's
definitely too so I've got them all
correct
why is no [ __ ] god damn it close the
door on my own face and I got scared
Dada Dada is 200 but oh my god oh I
didn't have all the bugs uh oh
well ain't that just a bag of dicks okay
here I have been trying to bash my head
against the wall being like you see more
King painted working it's cuz I didn't
have all of the books well holy [ __ ] I
thought I was being a big dumb dumb dumb
and here I was working on a puzzle with
some missing pieces well I fell ain't
that just ass TV s5a boink
ah I thought I had everything v IE I
which has could two on it I was
wondering when could Lulu was gonna show
up I knew I had it right I knew it was
being a bag of douches on me there YC CY
so these are the three that I did not
have and that should be everything that
we don't have so I just need to put
these in
okay so DVS v da da da da da
yes five I got that one five III dadada
all das y c cy da da da da okay so now
we've got dit da da da da as one and
then da da da da da as zero bit dick
dick da da as three dit da da da
as two so we've got everything that we
need I just need to tear him over one at
a time this is one so this is goes over
in the one pile the one column
everything else should still be in there
yeah but that goes in one okay bada bing
bada boom bada boom boom let me back let
me back he's gonna get me
okay so next up is five ie I which was a
[ __ ] goddammit my god damn [ __ ] thing
alright
five ie I which is zero this goes all
the way up there was a number on the
side for that six okay oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then we've got TBS five
branches to the da da da da da da da
which should be three ah is that a three
that's a three it's a wonderful three hi
I got it who'da thunk see what the hell
is this
hey I'll blind you over there I'll blind
the monster maybe okay well that didn't
help
okay so but we do have we do have more
numbers zero six let me put them in
order that they are in zero six okay
zero six eleven I know that doesn't
pause the game I'm in trouble okay
through six twenty one thirty unless
it's backwards it might be I'd be
backwards thirty but this would make
sense you I'll blind you I'm blind in
you I'm blind in you get blinded oh that
doesn't seem to be working I'm gonna
blind you something about laser pointers
and mirrors probably get lasered get
face laser that's not working okay
alright then
kids laser faced I don't know hey okay
but I have a laser pointer
maybe if I uh maybe if I put this in the
statute
if I put this in the statue will it out
put it it might do that hey there oh
[ __ ]
that what I'm doing hello did it it
didn't say transfer to my world
what are you kidding me it better be in
my better be in my goddamn folder no
whoa did I just lose it no oh there it
is okay so that didn't work holy [ __ ] I
thought I lost that I need this thing
maybe boom one okay so it's gotta be
something over here the level didn't
change
well Amira seem to be tinted red down is
the thing Shibuya won't okay so I guess
the only difference is this map is here
three seconds Oh
oh that's a thing slash at star star
star star star star star so seven
numbers seven numbers are there so that
might correlate to the seven numbers on
the sides of these books so / @ / at
number number period number number comma
number number I just know that guy's
gonna come out freak slash at period
comma period comma okay I think I can
remember that flash flash at okay I
think I got it I think I think I know
what it is that's not right okay so it's
slash at six one period 100 comma 99
period 4 comma 64 was it did say 64 I
can't remember what it said I find I
might not have gotten that but in slash
at number number period number number
comma number number period number comma
number number period 6z whoa whoa whoa
hey that's quick 6 zo6 said not 6 4 6
said I almost had it
okay all right bye gonna type this into
the computer okay so the code is slash
at six 1.1 0.9 9.4 or comma whatever you
slash at six 1.10 uh common 99.4 comma
6z dammit slash at maybe maybe Han
it might be coordinates it is it is a
mapable coordinate but where is that why
is it sixty it's it's literally in the
middle of nowhere it's in the middle of
Russia
oh so it's a random location in the
middle of Russia okay it's nothing it's
a whole lot of it's literally nothing
but oh it's on the map oh [ __ ] that
doesn't know that dammit that doesn't
help me
okay normal map please okay but it's in
Russia just straight above Mongolia and
if I'm if I'm assuming this correctly it
gave me a laser pointer to point at it
for six seconds three seconds if I'm not
mistaken which I might be mistaken so
where are you are right there
No
[Music]
oh yay oh yes yes whoa I miss mom
smiling to you I miss us it lied
oh he okay oh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no what if we got here you want it hello
a place and two I didn't mean to do that
it made layers of memories oh no oh my
god but now it's over oh my god these
layers are shattered
these mirror layers oh hello Oh
are we back Oh is everything the same oh
god it's dark over here why does this go
nowhere now oh no oh jeez there we go
okay all right then okay oh yeah oh that
was the room to where the statue was all
those so good oh my god that was so good
everything about that was awesome I
can't believe this came out of a game
jam but then again a lot of great ideas
do come out of game jams and that's why
game jams are very important because
this is a phenomenal game and this was a
phenomenal experience the puzzle
combined with the threat of the enemy
and and it was just short enough like in
reality it was just short enough that
the enemy became like stayed a kind of a
threat the whole time even though you
know it was it was easy to get by him
but he could still surprise you because
you didn't know when he was coming out
and just also the influence that maybe
maybe that enemy was you in the
reflection of that mirror or was that
another rumor were you looking at at
someone we were you thinking about like
you had a brother or something or or
twin I don't know there's a lot of
interpretations that come out of that in
considering that you miss mom and then
father's bastard
and then I don't know there's a lot of
things to go about this but the thing to
remember is now this game has gotten
such recognition that the developers are
going to make more
find version for it on Steam and release
it fully which I highly encourage them
to do this is a great idea it's a great
concept to have other people involved in
solving puzzles and also not holding
their hand making people rely on others
is a really cool way to go about things
and I really appreciate that
that's legitimately cool and I love that
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and thank you everybody that
participated in this experience I hope
you had a good time because I definitely
did so thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye